herzlich willkommen zu einem video okay
wenn dafür raus kam bis auf jeden fall
gestört denn ich fliege heute über kiew
in der ukraine nach astana war ich dort
in ankara anderen östlichen zipfel vom
krater seinem vortrag auch der expo ich
mache ich mir sorgen manchmal
mitzunehmen und gucken der reiseverkehr
wird auf jeden fall eine sehr schöne
erfahrung erstmal zweites mal aus europa
die zwischenläufe gleich nach vier von
düsseldorf treffen ist an den partner
manager
wirklich sagen mit am besten daran
gefällt mein tag zu glauben ist dass
wenn eine kamera also anschauen als
sturmgewehr in der hand werk möchte er
weniger viele von euch werden sich
wahrscheinlich fragen warum ist es
aufgabe der hintergrund der sache ist
dass ich dem zeigen wie man richtig
zuweilen gern spielt bergerfahrung vom
rio ferdinand nicht persönlich der
mainzer historiker haben ich bin nicht
so gut in minecraft stücke ein bisschen
besser werden kann wer tipps geben
vorstellen
liga die flughafenautobahn
heute bei dem pflichtete auch wichtig
damit ihre weiterreise habe ja ungefähr
eine stunde verspätung haben und ich
ungefähr bist du weniger was euer
lieblings videowagen ist
wir sind in der ukraine eigentlich jetzt
hier auf meinen ehemaligen manager
patrick hatten damit mehr astana wie ich
habe ihn nicht gesehen in dem fall ich
habe keinen plan ob film nach dieser
vorschrift sind würden bewaffnet der
ukraine ankommt
[Musik]
sobald alles normal
jemand der an meiner uni stücke einer
linie mit dem man einfach ausprobieren
viele treffen
[Musik]
weniger kamera
wir machen uns alle sorgen
vermutlich werden kann
ein mikrofon
damit haben architekten für verhöre euch
keine zeit mehr wirklich arbeiten
dieser marke
die wird in den gesprächen sitzt derzeit
vier uhr morgens für nacht in
deutschland
es ist mitternacht bei 14 vergleichen
der abgeholt nächsten ich man kann sehen
wollte
in deutschland macht unbemerkt beides
ist die erste nacht einfach so
[Musik]
erstere erste fertig wohl auch
tatsächlich auch von einem anderen
polizisten an geladen hatte dachte ich
habe mir richtig spaß gemacht ich hab
mir auch gefilmt aber ich mir nicht
sicher werde ich den zeige dass es
vielleicht ins gefängnis wegen der
rapper wieder bis ich wieder in
deutschland und wird persönlich
vorgeschlagen die hier keinem einklang
abonnieren wohnt hier geht es zur neuen
folge von spaß geht von unitymedia auf
jeden fall abstecken leute zuschauen
[Musik]